good morning Hank it's Sunday January 18
2009 the day before the day before
Barack Obama will be sworn in as the
44th President to the United States in a
related story I just got an email saying
that if I look closely I will see Barack
Obama taking the oath of office on the
Koran Oh Internet you are a tennis ball
and I am a puppy you baffle and
infuriate me and yet I never tire a
review ok Hank first a refresher course
in case you don't remember civics in the
United States we directly elect a
president every four years then a few
months later that someone promises to
preserve protect and defend the United
States Constitution at which point he or
she but thus far generally he becomes
president whereupon his first act as
president is to give a speech that is
too long and contains too many
adjectives I mean Hank if you like
adjectives and I do January 20th is an
extremely exciting day but let's clear
something up first Barack Obama is
taking the oath of office with his hand
on the Bible in fact he's using the
exact same Bible that Abraham Lincoln
used but so what if he weren't Hank he
wouldn't be the first president in
American history
in fact both John Quincy Adams and
Franklin Pierce took the oath of office
with their hands on books of law does
that make them bad presidents actually
they were both really bad presidents
that is true but you like Teddy
Roosevelt don't you yeah I don't know he
was good enough that we carved his face
on a mountainside well when he took the
oath of office he didn't put his hand on
anything he was just like you guys want
me to be President all right I'll do it
as long as you named teddy bears after
me in fact tank the whole putting your
hand on the Bible thing almost never
happened at all on the day of the first
presidential inauguration in 1789
someone was like hey do you think we
should use a Bible and then someone else
was like yeah does anyone have a Bible
but no one did so they literally had to
run down to a Masonic Lodge where they
took that is stole a Bible and then
George Washington put his hand on it and
became president Hank the story of the
first inaugural Bible is just one of
many examples from early American
history where it becomes clear that the
people who were involved had no freaking
idea that what they were doing would
later become so important to us for
instance maybe someday I'll tell you the
story of how the Declaration of
Independence almost didn't happen
because a dude got drunk at a bar but
the much more important thing that
happens on Tuesday the one that comes
after the oath but before the parties is
the inaugural address
Hank inaugural addresses while they are
important are usually pretty boring to
listen to and while Barack Obama is a
great speech writer I suspect that his
will be boring too but I do have one
small piece of advice for
president-elect Obama and I know that he
will hear me because of course he is a
gigantic fan of the vlogbrothers William
Henry Harrison
Hank as I'm sure you remember William
Henry Harrison was elected in a
landslide in 1840 and then on his very
cold inauguration day he refused to wear
a coat because he wanted to look all
presidential which probably would have
been fine except he gave a two-hour
eight thousand four hundred forty-four
word inauguration speech the longest
ever then he got pneumonia and died 31
days into his presidency so keep it
short Barack and wear a coat and
congratulations Hank I'll see you in a
new America on Tuesday
you